you don't go pushing the issue you don't  push a confrontation you got some  ptarmigan my food supplies get a little  bit lower than I like ptarmigans our  tasty little meals she doesn't see me  he's getting ready to fly  look up little Tommy  damn there's none of them  who got to here the original mission was  to check for predators that was worth it  though I got some birdies just a nice  little addition for my food supply when  I've got a tasty little meal for dinner  day I found out about the animals in my  area right now I'm seeing bear activity  I need to take notice I need to pay  attention until it gets within a mile  1/2 mile account I don't need to worry  but I need to be aware